the reason I announced this commit
committee this House Select Committee on
to address the Karuna of our crisis is
so that we can in the here-and-now
address as we go forward with
transparency and accountability House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi launching an
oversight committee with subpoena power
to oversee the Trump administration's
response to Co vid 19 here three action
is House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
he joins us from Capitol Hill leader
isn't that what Congress is supposed to
do aren't they supposed to provide
oversight to the administration yes and
we're already providing that thank for
one moment you have the oversight
committee that that's all they focus
upon but in the last bill that we just
passed the cares act we created three
new oversight entities right we created
the pandemic oversight that is a set up
of Inspector General's Glenn fine is
running that we created a special
individual who will be appointed by the
president confirmed by the Senate and
then we actually created a congressional
oversight that is appointed by all the
leaders from Schumer to McConnell to
Pelosi and myself this is redundant but
what's most telling here is who she
appointed she didn't go with the
oversight committee chair her own she
appointed Clyburn and remember what
Clyburn said that her Majority Whip he
said this is a time to restructure into
their vision government this isn't about
oversight sounds like pure politics
really what this speaker should be
focused on what we need to deliver to
the American public let's take care of
the crisis of at hand right now we have
five different oversights already
looking at this and this is what she
comes up with we need to implement the
trillions of dollars that we just said
that we passed let's get it to small
business let's get people continuing to
working let's make sure we get that
hundred and forty billion out to the
hospitals who actually needed the are
modern-day soldiers in the medical
community yeah you know it sounds like
there are a number of Democrats
including Speaker Pelosi who's already
talking about phase four we
barely got in Phase three started right
now but when you listen to some of her
some of her agenda items regarding phase
four it does sound like it's a lot of
what the Democrats proposed in January
the only difference is now they've added
some money for hospitals and community
clinics right well what she's proposing
is the things that she was denied in the
last bill things that had nothing to do
with coronavirus the green New Deal
changing election law billing out states
on pensions that has spent incorrectly
providing more money to sanctuary cities
everything that doesn't deal with the
coronavirus Planned Parenthood these are
the things that why she held this bill
up for more than four days I mean this
would already be implemented today we'd
be talking about how we're getting the
money out had she not held the bill up
earlier you know since phase three is
now underway and it sounds like some
people are gonna wind up getting checks
as early as next week
as a former small business owner
yourself you know I think you've started
a business when you were about 20 years
old how important is it for people who
are finding these times so challenging
with their small business that they get
on the website and start the process of
getting the money that is out there for
them today this is the most important
thing to do this bill does a number of
things but what it does with small
business is very important if your sole
proprietor your small business where I
was when I was 20 years old government
has shut you down too most of those
small businesses so you have no income
we want to provide you liquidity it's
only a two-page form that you have to
fill out it's out there you can go to my
Twitter page I'll have it up there GOP
leader to be able to send it to you but
what it will do is if you pay your
employees you pay your rent you pay your
utilities that's no longer alone a
portion of that is a grant we want to
keep people working we want to supply
you the resource if your larger business
will secure a loan give you a retention
tax credit to pay for half of your
employees individuals will get a check
directly to them if they're making
ninety nine thousand dollars or less and
the hospital's get resources that's what
the cares Act did and that
we should be focused on making sure
we're implementing instead of looking at
some other bill or some other oversight
because we just instituted three new
oversight committees to see that oversee
this right
speaking of oversight speaker Pelosi
spokesman said regarding the Oversight
Committee quote this bipartisan
committees work will help save lives and
taxpayer dollars in real time not after
it's too late to make a difference and
that's something everyone should welcome
your response to that well that's just
not true I mean has she not learned from
the impeachment I maybe that's what
she's thinking about here you cannot
create a new select committee without
Congress voting I'm here because I'm
meeting with the president today but
nobody else is here in Washington when
would we come back and vote on this now
it would be too late that's why in the
cares Act we implemented three new
oversight entities within there that she
has an appointment to but we already
have the oversight committee only to
focus on this and we also have every
single committee has an oversight
subcommittee it seems to me that this is
just politics as usual
instead of focused on the crisis that we
need to be today delivering for the
American public making sure we're
getting the resources to them well Kevin
McCarthy all alone on Capitol Hill sir
thank you very much thank you good to
hear it from you regarding all these
things in the news thank you sir